is that a true enough Story the answer
is yes and no depends on the guy I don't
believe and I want to clarify I do not
believe every man should get married if
I'm 18 years old I'm with my high school
sweetheart we're broke we're living in
freaking West Virginia should we get
married heck no of course not you have a
99.9 divorce rate it is the dumbest
thing on planet Earth so what I like to
do we're actually working on on this
process I'm glad that you asked me we're
working on like this
um marriage evaluator where we take all
these different variables in the
individual and see what is the projected
divorce rate right we still have we're
still fixing it we're still playing
around with it so if a man needs certain
criteria right so if a man knows his
purpose he's financially sound he's
physically fit he's emotionally healthy
he's spiritually grounded and he meets
certain criteria and he wants to bring
in the right woman because it's not just
so much you being the right man she also
has to be the right woman right and then
then obviously you you gotta have the
conversation with the marriage mediator
if you want to do the prenups and things
along those lines if you're willing to
do all those things go through the
pre-engagement counseling and all that
stuff I support it I actually have I'm
not I think the straw man to my argument
is every man should get married no
matter what age and social no no it's a
very specific man that we that I believe
should get married and I believe every
man should work to become that man and
once he's that man I believe marriage is
in his best interest yeah that's
basically what I was saying about supply
and demand become a guy who's in high
demand and there'll be a ton of Supply
out there so so you think if a guy does
all those things he should get married
would you say legally to
um it's up to him to decide so for me I
have I have guys who are Christians I
have guys who are Muslims I have guys
who are atheist Buddhists so me I'm
never going to tell you how you choose
to get married because I the reason why
I obviously you don't advise on that um
because that's a religious conversation
because I'm a Christian but remember
like the majority of the world I mean
like what percent of America's
Christians like an actually majority of
majority of Americans that's different
okay even though people let me give you
an example
go ahead okay go ahead
if a guy gets to a certain percentage
like do you advise him you do advise him
to get legally married so when it comes
to the legalities not legally yes or no
oh no and yes it depends on the person
because it depends on the person if
somebody is you advise yes if they're
religious and then otherwise so in
regards to them choosing about marriage
it depends upon the person I have Muslim
people who they say my name is Hafiz
Hafiz means one memorizes the Quran I am
the only Christian in the entire Bible
lineage and who's a male most my family
are Muslim so a lot of my Muslim family
they get they get married in um in Islam
they don't get married via the state I'm
not going to say no you should follow my
Christian or dudes and get married to
this day you're free to do whatever you
want because in Islam you believe what
you believe and so to me that's why I
said depending on the religion depending
on the background I give different
advice for different people that's why
one of the things I want to ask one last
thing people don't realize I've stopped
doing videos I've stopped doing content
in 2022 literally in 2021 I did 81
individual videos in 2022 I did five why
I've stopped been doing content right
now all we do is we have these
conversations with real life men we get
to know them we hear their stories we
hear their struggles we give them tools
and resources and we give specific
advice the biggest problem with the
internet what I can agree with you Pearl
if you believe this or not is the
internet gives you vague advice so some
advice can work for some man but doesn't
mean it works for other men you want to
give as specific advice as advice as
possible and therefore you must know
that man as best as possible so recently
based upon how I know that man will be
based on how I give him the advice okay
I was just curious your thought process
like so Christian does all the things
you say
yes or no recommend legal legal not not
ceremony Christian yes legal okay so if
he's Christian yes fits in that category
high value man whatever you think
legally he should get married yes and
protect himself okay okay protect
himself how yeah so this do it with a
prenup yeah so this is a myriad of ways
of protecting yourself so Natalie if you
don't mind can you go ahead and go back
to the data real quick
um
so um
go ahead and scroll down down
a little bit further oh you're just at
the bottom can you scroll up Alex scroll
the way down Pearl
um
scroll up the bottom one um number six
marriage mediation agreements
um great so that's a great article for
you guys to read to learn a little bit
more about mayor's mediation from a
lawyer's perspective so this is
something that I think guys need to do
so what happens is before you get
married you find that you get a marriage
mediator and I and depending on it stays
different laws and what you would do is
she would she'll sit you down and walk
through every detail of marriage how
much money you were you planning on
making
um what what um responsibilities each
person is going to have and then through
the mediation then the mediator will
work with the lawyer to coin the prenup
but this is very important because it
identifies what you expect out of that
marriage so these are additional ways a
man can protect himself by making sure
that if you're marrying a woman you guys
you and her are crystal clear you know
in regards to what you expect and then
if you want to go ahead and go through
the the do the premarital agreement aka
the prenup there's other things you can
do as well as well as if you want to
protect yourself from alimony there's
things that you do as well all these
resources we give to our guys in the
community we're constantly giving all
these two tools all this information for
them to win the most in life did
you no I didn't
oh why
in my personal because you'd recommend
the guy to get the prenup everyone is
different okay I'm not going to force
anybody to do it some people believe it
some people don't I personally I
personally me personally this is how
thesis persons is not Gods this is not
my best advice for men today I
personally believe for my wife the 50 50
makes sense for my wife it makes sense
to me so would you be willing to say
that you're the exception 100 okay and I
and I can say I would never I would
never advise anyone to do what I'm doing
this is my personal conviction what if
it ended up that you would it was less
than 50 50. like money let me tell you
the secret person so I'm just going to
say say and I I don't wish the song used
to don't you know but in 10 years right
and it's not 50 50. she takes 70 80
let's do 99. okay let's go freaking 99.
let's say she takes 99 of the money
know what I have Adam
this what's really interesting is I
would I would advise people to look up
top
um divorce the the divorce the top
divorce payouts in U.S history and see
the guys who had a top divorce payouts
you know what happened to almost every
single last one of those guys Adam they
became even richer after their divorces
you know why because you can take away
their money you can never take away the
man's mind you can take away Tiger Woods
Money oh never mind they did take his
mind to it but Michael Jordan you can't
take away his mind
um the the what's the dude's um the
Amazon do Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos so what
happens is to me the mind of the man you
will always be successful that's me
personally guys don't don't apply this
to your life so I personally believe me
personally I'm not I'm not a big money
guy I'm a very simplistic guy like you
you know if my if my family's taking
care of every everything is good you can
you can give me let me hit Ground Zero
take all my YouTube subscribers take all
my YouTube followers heck give her the
freaking house give her everything guess
what's gonna happen in three years I'm
gonna be right back that's the kind of
mindset I have I gotta I gotta give you
some push back
yeah and I'm sure the chat's going wild
over here yeah
um and I'm glad before I even give you
the pushback I'm glad that you're saying
this is me I'm not advising this for you
because I think no man should do this so
for me yeah like I am hypocritical isn't
that hypocritical ever no because
everybody's different now you're
interrupting me I'm sorry I'm sorry I
did it I'm sorry I'm sorry oh God okay
I'll mess with it yeah but so for me
like I have friends that are going
through a divorce right now uh one
really really uh close friend and I know
what he's built okay and he's given the
wife half the house
um and rightfully so they raise the
family in the house 50 50 cool they're
split in the house it's worth a handful
a million dollars it's a Miami great
awesome but now she's getting 50 of his
business this guy is a successful
business this woman she didn't do [__]
yeah to help with the business okay and
for me that is a very very tough thing
let me go deeper bro please be pleased
let's say that I'm worth 10 million
dollars okay and my wife like you gave
the 99 number by the way
I mean that's why I'm giving you the
pushback yeah yeah
and I want you to to think about this if
I'm worth 10 million dollars and we get
a divorce and I'm left with a hundred
grand and my wife gets 9.9 million
dollars it's ridiculous that's where as
a dude is gonna go jump off a [__]
Bridge 100 and I want to clear that out
and I want to clarify yeah
that was extreme it was extreme number
the point that I made is that when it
comes to the the prenuptial agreement
everybody's prenuptial agreement is
different whatever you feel comfortable
with that's what you should have so my
point is that if some men feel
comfortable with 50 50 some men say hey
if we get divorced you get this stipend
you get whatever you want to come up
with me personally this is my opinion
I'm not saying it's fact I'm saying this
is my personal opinion people are going
to use this to go against me it is how I
feel that's just what I I think the 50
50 from for my wife for my particular
wife I believe it makes sense I'll say
one thing and then I'm gonna turn it
over to our friend Pearl yeah
of these you've been making content
about men's self-improvement for how
long
um I writing or video Everything uh
probably for 13 years so meaning when
you got married you knew exactly what
you were doing 100 you weren't like well
it's just science that's it you very you
were very intentional you said I'm doing
this for a reason yeah I've I'm very
clear-eyed and and open-hearted as to I
I am confident in my situation and I
know that most men shouldn't do this but
here's what I'm willing to do because
I'm very aware of what I'm doing as far
as getting married bringing up I was
like meeting like you didn't get like
Bamboozled at all no no and that's why
I'm okay with your decision because you
actively consciously logically made that
decision and nobody out there whether
you agree with the fees or [__]
disagree with the fees
like you know what you're you're gonna
get bamboozled that's my point yeah and
that's why if that's your decision
that's your decision and one and one of
the things I also want to talk about in
regards to because when people talk
about marriage and the state what people
don't realize is that when it comes to
marriage and the state the state has
almost always been a marriage one of the
common misnomers is that the state was
never in marriage and all of a sudden in
the western marriage and say all of a
sudden went into marriage if you go back
to one of the oldest ancient laws which
is Hammurabi's Codes there is literally
codes and rules literally Rules by an
ancient Mesopotamia where there's where
there's rules that if a wife leaves a
husband she got nothing which I think is
a great Rule and pearl would love that
rule and if a husband left his wife with
children he must provide a sustainable
living so I know people are going to
straw man my argument Youth and use this
point to make their Clips every man
should do what he believes is best if
you want to give your wife zero give her
zero if you want to give her half give
her half whatever you feel is best as a
man that's what I advise I'm just
sharing my opinion we did an episode
yesterday and I want to give you the
takeaway that I thought whether you
agree with this person disagree with
this person I'm just letting you know
what I took away from TLA what he said
yesterday he said before you get married
spend 500 or a thousand bucks and meet
with an attorney and just understand
what you're getting yourself into 100
knowledge is power that's great advice
step two
I'm advising you this is him get a
prenup yeah whatever the prenup says you
figure out step three do a personality
test that's great as to make sure that
the person that you're marrying you guys
are in the same wavelength I think again
I'm not a lawyer this is not my personal
advice I'm recording this but I think
that is very applicable advice for today
the lovely Pearl go ahead your response
well prenups can be thrown out too and
I'm so I think that's something that men
should be aware of as well so do you
know why to get thrown out Pearl
um I mean it for state to state of
course
um so I like there's one that if if they
do the prenup like too close to the
marriage basically they um they'll say
she was under duress of course basically
so you can't like throw your throw your
girlfriend up the day before there's
ways to do that there's ways to do it
right and there's ways to do it wrong I
love that and pearl that's fantastic
guys listen to where Pearl said because
that's what we both can agree on it's
very important that you educate yourself
on the prenup educate yourself because
each state is different as well as
educate yourself how it is thrown out
because like I said my biggest thing is
I I want to help men win in this
environment we know these laws that
educate yourself okay if we know that
prenups are throwing out these seven
different ways protect yourself in these
seven different ways however the problem
still is it's up to the judge and judges
differ and you can't really predict what
judge you're going to get so which goes
back to what I was saying I I just I
understand why men just avoid this chaos
my question to you Pearl is how many
percent of prenups is done the right way
of throwing way
how much what percent yeah I don't
actually know exactly so the fundamental
reason you don't know
okay come here thank you
um no it's it's not that every woman
will it's that every woman can
and that that's that's the point A lot
of times they're like that they're
talking about it's like that's a lot of
power to give someone because it goes
back to you're signing a contract with
other person has benefited to leave you
could do this you could put the prenup
in and help avoid a situation and maybe
most of the time it will but the whole
point is
they're looking for a reason to throw it
out and there's even lawyers that have
come forward and say I don't believe
prenups work final thoughts
my point is this when we're giving
people we have to give them practical
advice no
we're not giving advice we're not giving
advice you give advice sorry that's a
fair statement because she's got an
advice
can I talk now Pearl is that okay with
you yeah I'll let you thank you so much
bro so to me one of the one of the
biggest things in regards to that
statement is people can do anything
right don't get friends because they can
stab you in your back because a friend
stabs you in your back don't drive a car
because you can get in a crash don't
anything can happen my desire is to help
men alleviate the risk that happen yes
is there a percentage of one percent
chance you can throw your prenup can be
thrown away of course there's always a
risk I want to give men the best odds
possible to win in this environment and
so man if you look if you're looking to
get a prenup make sure you go to your
individual State understand the specific
loss for your state understand what what
cases in your state do prenup was thrown
about protect yourself to be able to
have the best life possible that's my
advice for men to win the most premiums
can be thrown out if the judge sees
something that makes them deemed unfair
and if we're going to use the car
analogy So Adam I got a question for you
oh she was waiting for this one so okay
if you were driving your car right and
you found out that at the intersection
they're paid to hit you they're paid
they're given money to hit you at the
intersection would you understand if
guys maybe we're like you know what I'm
gonna stop at this light and not go
through
uh well full disclosure I haven't had a
car in 10 years
everywhere to avoid nonsense like this
but to address your actual question yeah
I'm not looking for drama I'm gonna
avoid that but I think that's like the
perspective but it's like why do all
this one there's a difference a men are
built to protect and provide that's the
purpose of man Patrick David we love
Patrick shout out Patrick I know you're
not watching this but I love you
shout out Pastor bet David Patrick Davis
said what is that Jewish proverb every
man should do three things yeah write a
book plan a tree have a son yeah I
believe that men are living their
fullest potential when they're
protecting providing leading a family
yes anyone cannot drive the intersection
but are we telling men to never have
families never to live their their
potential never to experience no I'm not
telling them to do anything
can I finish my conversation go ahead
thank you thank you thank you thank you
David advised go ahead Adam no all good
we we we're going to switch topics here
I think we've we've exhausted the
marriage and divorce content of course
we're going to have short clips about
marriage and divorce for the next decade
we're good I got we're good let's move
on to a couple of things we were talking
about the concept of men leading women
follow Natalya and I kind of what your
what your parents do about like the the
father your as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible